are you looking for an immersive musical
festival that kills the competition or
perhaps a festival that pushes the
boundaries of the impossible then
welcome to Redwood fest yes it's episode
7 of American Horror Story 1984 and
thinks story is here with a detailed
breakdown theories and what we can
expect for the final few episodes so
strap yourselves in because here we go
it's camp golden star in 1948 that is
the ugliest-looking beach ball notice
the white flag here a totally different
logo and look than that of camp redwood
you can even see it on the uniforms the
counselors have to wear in five cents
for three licorice whips breath but it's
all made up for with the introduction of
a big HS alum Lily rabe she's been in
every season of Horror Story except for
season sevens cult in this season she
plays Lavinia Richter mr. jingles mother
who is also referred to as the lady in
white which is the title of the episode
named after her white nightgown
yes that's Bobby Richter alongside his
brother Ben fun note been named his son
the one in Alaska Bobby in honor of his
little brother Ben is a bit of a loner
preferring to stay in and read comics
then go out and play with others we also
see more of this family dynamic where
Bobby is treated well and been
continually chastised by her mother for
not being normal Lavinia has taken over
as the camp cook she's a widow with
Ben's father having died in World War
two there's a fun nod to birdie here as
she's preparing PB&J sandwiches just
like birdy did on the night of her death
Bobby wants to go swimming so Lavinia
and trust Ben with looking after him
what we're here at the docks where the
campers enjoy a nice day cooling off by
the lake Ben tries to make conversation
with some of the girls but he's about as
socially awkward as I am and they just
bully him he catches sight of the
lifeguard and one of the counselors
venturing off into the woods and does
what any boy would do and totally pervs
with his eyes on the wrong prize Bobby
is left unattended and is viciously
skewered by a boat propeller Ben tries
to warn the boat but it's too late
Lavinia fumes at the counselor
and been for not watching after her son
holding them responsible for his death
this is almost identical to the plot of
Friday the 13th spoiler alert
where mrs. Voorhees goes on a killing
rampage because the counselors were busy
having sex while her son drowned in the
lake back in present-day which for us is
1989 Donna brings a fresh off death row
Brooke back to her hotel room we find
out that Donna used baclofen a muscle
relaxant instead of the regular lethal
injection to trick the prison into
thinking Brooke was dead the detox
however is so painful that Donna has to
tie Brooke up until it passes there's a
fun little nod to Neil Patrick Harris
says Brooke watches him on the 80s
program Doogie Howser
you might remember Neil as Chester CREB
in season fours freak show Donna picks
up some jack-in-the-box please sponsor
me and is told she'll be given a new
passport and identity now that she's
free but Brooke isn't having it the last
time she was with Donna five years ago
she had her strung up as serial killer
bait what's changed well Donna is
looking for redemption she's seen the
error of her ways and wants to make
things right I know there are things
waiting for us when we die I'm just
trying to make sure that I go with the
good things on the other place she does
want to turn out like her father who we
saw in the beginning of episode 5 was a
serial killer now I don't know what you
guys thought but when Donna conveniently
put the app for the camp red would fast
knowing Brooke would read it and make me
think she's pulling some sort of reverse
psychology that she secretly wants
Brooke to come to camp red would but hey
that could just be me when Brooke sees
the ad she knows what she must do kill
Margaret for the five years she spent on
death row and being framed for a
murderer I do have a reason to live it's
to see her die and Brooke didn't even
finish her burger Donna takes Brooke to
a roller rink to let out some steam hell
she's been cooped up for years might at
least have some fun and we get a cheesy
80s style montage of the two of them
enjoying themselves they even have some
licorice whips like the boy ordered in
the beginning hey and for someone who
just got of death row Emma is looking
fine in the back however is a character
closely watching them portrayed by H as
Salaam dylan mcdermott he's been in four
seasons of the show
Murder House asylum apocalypse and now
1984 Brooke reiterates that she's going
back to Redwood nothing is gonna stop
her when Bruce approaches or at least
that's how he introduces himself to the
girls on IMDB and the subtitles his
character is named Alex so he may just
be using an alias here since we'll find
out he's the serial killer that has been
plaguing women along the California
Highway he tells them that his car broke
down outside a roller rink and he needs
a ride to his girlfriend to the festival
they initially say no but when they find
their car doesn't work and he comes to
save the day
they offer to give him a ride and Donna
after waving her no stranger policy says
the best line of the episode once the
guys going under my hood he's not a
stranger anymore damn in the back of the
car bruce seems to be enjoying the
devil's dust and Brooke is immediately
suspicious bruce tells them an urban
legend about a guy who stalks cars in
the night which is likely his way of
telling them that the legend is based
off of him
Brooke feels uncomfortable and demands
he get of the car when a state trooper
pulls up behind them asking if
everything is okay out of the blue Bruce
shoots the officer and decides to get
out of the car giving Donna and Brooke
time to get away let this be a lesson to
everyone out there always pick up
hitchhikers shingles is copycat
wide-load yes that's his actual name
they gave his character is trying to
take a piss just like he did in his
first episode which I guess confirms
that ghosts still have to piss jingles
is ambushed by the other pranksters who
he thought he had killed we learned that
Montana seems to be running the show
telling the others to save their kills
for the big festival as we later learn
when jingles is brought before the dead
Montana's plan is to create a massacre
so large it attracts media attention
from around the world specifically
paranormal investigators who she
believes may be able to help break the
curse that has kept them trapped on the
camp redwood property now the whole gang
is here except for birdy
what gives chef birdy is good people
notice also that Ben's younger brother
isn't there as well
the simplest explanation for that is
that he died before lavinia's death
which supposedly caused the blood curse
which plagues them all however there
could be a world in which it's actually
the spirit of
Bobbe which is causing this curse
jingles tells them that he has come back
to kill Richard Ramirez the man who
killed his wife along with countless
others unlike the other campers Ramirez
has the devil on his side and that's how
the blood curse did not affect him
wandering montage I think one of these
strangest things in this scene is when
jingle starts questioning the ghosts
whether they can feel pain almost like
he's preemptively deciding if he wants
to kill himself like he ends up doing at
the end of the episode jingles learns
that her mother has been chasing around
the counselors because she hates them
for what they did to her boy we also get
a flashback of the first camp redwood
Massacre in which Lavinia killed all the
counselors for revenge when Ben finds
out what she did he runs away and is
stabbed in the leg a wound which has
caused his limp we've seen the entire
season
notice how when he's resurrected at the
very end that his limp is now gone Ben
ends up killing his own mother surmising
her blood had poured into this ground
with her pain and her rage maybe that's
why you're all still stuck here jingles
is spared and taken to the cabin where
Lavinia lives in the woods the cabin
also gives me the shack from Friday the
13 vibes jingles enters and finds a cup
and ball toy which belonged to his
brother now this is either a clue that
Bobby is still alive or it's simply a
memento Lavinia keeps to remind her of
her son but my guess is the latter since
Lavinia tells jingles she felt the
presence of her son in these 70s but was
disappointed when she found out it was
the wrong son Lavinia appears seemingly
with the power to teleport and this is
the worst mother-son fight since I told
my mom I wanted to go to film school
she's a total dick to jingles constantly
berating him for the death of Bobby
telling him that every day for her is
torture she was somewhat dormant for
20-plus years until jingles took the job
as janitor
she spoke into Margaret's ear a girl who
was already quite messed up in the head
and pushed her over the edge to kill the
other counselors it was a double victory
for Lavinia because she got to kill
counselors while destroying the one
thing Ben loved
and I used to destroy you Ben tells her
he's here to kill Ramirez but Lavinia
doesn't really seem to care she's still
mad as hell I will spend every moment
her now to Eternity making sure you burn
at a traffic stop Bruce rams the police
car into them and takes them hostage
when Brooke wakes up she finds that he
has tied Donna up to the back and wants
her to be the one to run her over she
can either hit the gas or get her face
blown off I know which one I'm choosing
his motivations are much like Ramirez to
be remembered telling Brooke that he
hopes to surpass Ted Bundy's kill count
Brooke outsmarts Bruce by smashing the
like button I mean hitting reverse
allowing her the opportunity to steal
his gun and shoot him in the leg Donna
and Brooke tie him up and Brooke goes
hardcore cutting off his thumb so he can
never hitchhike again remember Bruce
Karma's a [ __ ]
Brooke is gonna walk the rest of the way
to Redwood and Donna decides to come
with her while Trevor Margaret and
Courtney worked to put the finishing
touches on the poorly coordinated
festival seriously $1,000 a ticket who
would ever go to a festival for it Oh
Margaret keeps slinging the big dick
jokes come on Margaret hashtag all sizes
matter when the mall from the 80s band
kajagoogoo arrives you may have seen him
in my stranger things video as the voice
of neverending story
[Music]
check out that video if you have a
chance
Trevor ventures off into the woods where
he meets Montana remember back in
episode two he referred to her as his
soul mate so it remains to be seen
whether Montana will be using him for
more than just his meat stick
l'm all ends his never-ending story when
ricky comes to collect a deal he had
made with the devil a superstar career
provided to him by satan himself
Courtney brings a gift basket to the
catch a Cougar's catch a GU catch a
goose to find them all killed this is
seriously gonna impact the festival and
in our final scene jingles hangs by the
dock where his brother died when he's
visited once again by Lavinia he tells
her he thinks about papi every day and
reiterates his desire to kill Ricky
if jingles is gonna stand a chance
against Ricky he'll need to kill himself
now I felt the show could have done a
better job explaining how this all works
but it appears since jingles owes a debt
to Ricky and Satan if he were killed by
them he would be gone for good but if he
kills himself he'll be resurrected at
Camp redwood and become one of the
ghosts jingles feels that if he's going
to stand the best chance of defeating
Ricky and protecting his son he needs to
kill himself resurrecting in front of
his corpse ready to take on Ramirez
that's it for this episode of American
Horror Story make sure to LIKE subscribe
and leave your thoughts and theories in
the comments below you can also follow
me on twitter at things story whitey
until next time remember daddy loves you
very much